j'ai pas sorti de l'auberge mais c'est
pas fini pour elle et pas du tout je
reste jusqu'à maintenant non voici
l'interview confession c'est tout dire
c'est déjà rentré dans un confessionnal
non jamais eh ben tu vas voir aller sur
moi
ce mind tu ne sais pas si tu es le fils
d'un arabe d'un juif d'un militaire
français
si tu pouvais choisir tu choisirais quoi
mais justement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est justement je ne venais pas affreux
dire maintenant
vicent rap catholique et
je peux aujourd'hui affirmé quand un
coutelier un catholique et qu'on les
cons quant à lui c'est con il est con et
quand on aura des coûts il est qu'on
imagine qu'un jour il y ait une nouvelle
guerre entre la france et l'algérie tu
serais de quelques t oujours situerait
du côté de la raison est ce que tu te
souviens du jour où tu as le plus
détesté un français de france lui est
français
moi je dis toujours de voir les copains
je rencontre devant les potes et du
niçois mais les français sont racistes
je pense que la france n'est pas
essentiellement prince east d'espoir que
je reproche à la formation de banaliser
et 10 généralisée il faut pas
généraliser il faut se dire que la
france et les la france des différents
scellés
les différences d'opinion et les
les différences d'avis et on vit et la
démocratie ça c'est dire moi le pen il
existe il est là
il doit vivre justement il doit y dont
il doit exister dans la mesure où on
fait partie du jeu démocratique
je crois que la qualité de la france
justement comme la qualité de l'amérique
c'est justement d'avoir ce brassage de
différents se brasse ce brassage
l'identité qui fait vraiment la force la
force d'un dancing le couscous c'est
très très bon couscous et vous vous
n'hésitez pas à venir manger dans les
restaurants moins jusqu'aux parce que
tout le monde dit c'est bon un couscous
à la couscous et arabes le couscous est
chimie imagine qu'un jour tu es dans une
petite ville ou un village les gens
savent pas que ce mail
et puis quelqu'un te traite de sale
arabe je lui réponds propres j'éclate de
rire toi qui a été choisi par une bonne
soeur soeur cécile au milieu de tous les
orphelins de saint vincent de paul à
constantine qui a pu parce que tu as été
adopté par des parts des cabines vivant
en france à avoir la victoire
est-ce que tu ne vois pas derrière tu
dis l'étoile mais pourquoi ne pas y voir
dieu directement pourquoi encore se
cacher derrière seulement ce que tu
crois pas pour finir que tu as peur
depardieu non puisque j'y crois